do you guys believe in child support
well i don't i don't ask for child
support oh okay cool i do i feel um i
feel like it should happen but like i
said i'm realistic if
my child is not
an item that needs to be managed my
child so i'll look after you i'll do
what i need to if you can't think of
doing the same as a father then that's
on you
if that if the father pays like child
support do you think he should get 50 50
custody with the chart with the child if
you want to yeah no
oh no
why not because some fathers choose to
pay child support because they don't
want to be in the child's life
so
if i'm talking about the ones that do
the ones that do yeah we were talking
about the fathers that do want to be in
their child's life um do i believe in
child support in that instance
um depending on how the situation played
out i think that one is circumstantial
you see when it comes to 50 50 i think
no offense it's all about your parenting
skills for me if your parenting skills
don't align
then or your parenting skills are not a
positive impact on the child then i
don't think you should have 50 50
because it confuses the child if we
can't sit make that decision we can sit
down together
and say okay this is what i think like
for instance don't let the kids watch
certain things don't let kids eat drink
certain things so you know they must
read they must do that and if i see that
we've established that that's what
should happen and that's not being done
then you can't have 50 because the
things that we're asking for that i'm
asking for is something to benefit the
child it's not got anything personal to
do with me or to do with anything that i
think i think definitely is
no i'm saying like like because i i like
i come from a family of 10 and they were
very loose like we could pretty much do
whatever we wanted
from from like yeah no like really a lot
of freedom and everyone turned out good
they're functioning membership uh sorry
two-parent home yes yeah but that's
right and so i both agree right but what
i'm saying is that you how do you know
you're correct like maybe that's his
parenting style would have been better
yeah who's to say
i think it depends on actually having a
conversation
like she said because i feel like me
personally if for example you don't want
your kids to watch tv at three doesn't
necessarily mean i'm a bad parent
because i do 100 because my child
watches tv whatever she wants yeah but
that doesn't necessarily mean i'm
raising her the wrong way
if i'm seeing impacts of their behavior
changing at school and it's being raised
tomorrow it's been brought to my
attention and stuff like that then we
need to discuss like
whether we're not together that's so
different from these kids so we need i
believe when you choose to be a single
parent you have to realize that it's
probably harder than being in together
being together is a lot easier than
being a single parent so you now have to
learn how to have people skills
management skills all of that because
there's going to be some sort of
resentment
until you've healed right so i feel like
you have to be able to sit down and talk
together and say okay this is what i
want what do you want or this is what i
want okay let's meet halfway and if you
can't have those kind of conversations
together then
it's just going to be difficult well no
i agree it'll be difficult i just don't
like like to me that's not enough to ask
for not splitting custody my children
for me my children's upbringing is
enough for me to well i'm saying like i
don't think legally that's fair it may
not be fair legally but so many things
are not fair legally so well i know they
benefit the women typically but i've
said that yeah i've said that but um
there's some men as well they're not
happy with the way women bring
women as well not all women raise
children well mm-hmm so it's not i don't
even think it should be a based on
the message yeah i think i think it's
just who's who's a better parent and
it's hard you know what some people
won't accept him but some men are better
parents than women as well but no i i
agree but i'm saying i'm saying like off
the bat i think it should be 50 50.
and if there's no abuse it should stay
fifty-five i agree and i don't think
anyone's entitled to child support i
don't understand like why
you get a reward i think child's putting
up a home child support should be
offered to you if you are financially
not capable of looking to the child then
i think there's nothing wrong with that
but then shouldn't they just give the
child to the more financially stable
parent but financially being financially
stable doesn't make you a good parent
either it makes it much better for the
child i can give you money to like i can
give you so okay wouldn't you agree that
typically people that are financially
responsible typically are responsible in
other areas of their life
in general like i know there's
exceptions but we're talking about the
rule when i look at parents with
rich parents and their kids have gone to
private school those are the most
problematic kids well we're not talking
about wealth no i'm just referring
reflecting back to wealth so for me for
some reason money doesn't necessarily
make me feel like you're a good parent
you may be controlled in your life like
you may save well
what would you say indicates in a legal
perspective who's a good parent
you know what i think feelings are so
hard
things that you can't measure there's no
metrics
it's finances
yeah if you can make sure you're good
because i just don't know what else
because if you're
if you can't support yourself and a kid
on some on some level that says you were
irresponsible and typically you are
irresponsible in not just one area of
your life but in multiple i think
legally i think they look at a child's
stability
um finances are like definitely a big
part of it and obviously the support the
families the support system the unit and
i feel like that's very important so if
for example i'm like [ __ ] with finances
and i don't have families just me and my
child they could probably give the child
to the dad who has his brothers sisters
aunties uncles cousins and he's making
more a bit more money but in terms of
finances just because i'm struggling
with my child doesn't mean
a two like two income is always going to
be better than one so if he's given 200
pounds a month let's say
that doesn't affect him
in that way to make it seem like he's
more financially stable he could still
be giving 200 pounds and earning less
than me
to to look after a child takes however
much i think if he was living under the
same roof
the
the financial aspect will still be the
same exactly they will still be spending
money on their like child whether
they're living with their child or
whether they don't live with exactly
well yeah i mean i just think that i
don't like the idea of the government
like
forcing them to spend money but that's
only if it's not 50 50 though
even so i just don't think you're
entitled to a man's money what do you
think men put women on child support as
well i that's the exception it's not the
rule typically it's the other way around
and i'm not i'm not for that either i'm
not for child support at all so what do
you tell you what was it
what do you think what do you think
should happen i think like honestly you
should make better decisions of who you
make a kid with because like to me like
there's always a bailout for women if we
make a bad decision like someone always
bails us out
do you mean government government
everything so like for example if
someone gets fat there's fat phobic
right if someone if someone if someone
has a high body count sleeps around
they're [ __ ] shaming like they don't
have the equivalent of that for men um
in this instance i'm saying like you get
money from the government
i just believe or from or from the guy
so i wouldn't be able to comment on this
because i don't personally take child
support right i did make right i'm
decision with my baby father but that's
the choice i made and i'm dealing with
it no and that's that's the thing i
respect people that take accountability
but it's like it's like
to me i don't think anyone should bail
anyone out for their bad decisions so if
you choose to make a child with a less a
subpar guy i don't think you're entitled
to his money you should have picked
better but then the man's played just as
much of a part to create that child as
the woman no no though because women are
in charge of birth it's your own fault
if you get pregnant
because because
we have we have 10 to 15 forms of birth
control even if we get pregnant you can
get an abortion yeah but a man still has
to it's hot in here
yeah but yeah but the thing is a man
having access to a woman's body